you came along
what was the plan to kill all of you and
then believe and now with all our guns
out I'll manage
you're the fastest 65 year old white guy
on the planet I guess I'm done
you are officially retired how are you
gonna spend your golden years huh
I missed you now since I'm retired I'm
gonna meet my wife back what's gonna
stop us 15 year old divorce papers she
doesn't love you anymore
boo can I talk to you for a minute
we're going to lose an operative
code names Panda I'm retired
you've been extract Panda grabbed the
wmd zip on now
Dollar in the swear jar I remember the
wmd store so follow me or get out of my
way
it has daddy issues
she treats me like a child alcohol
cigarettes and the garish lipstick
that's not lipstick oh my gosh vibrating
oh my God tell me now take your daughter
to work day is going well
Emma I'm okay just take him out
what
I've learned a ton from working with my
dad
how he leads the team how he keeps his
cool how to Slit a man's throat
vertically so he bleeds out faster they
got more issues than Sports Illustrated
that was on me this is totally
end the marriage before you do you think
I'm a virgin well let me think what I
want to think oh my God I'm 28.